we're talking with JD in Minneapolis
he's been dating a young lady for two
years she refuses to discuss her debt
with him they're discussing marriage she
wants to buy a home before they're
married with an FHA loan because she
doesn't have any money to put down and
he wants to know how to handle both
issues with her is that a fair summary
of what you told me sir yes I wouldn't
be paying for the house until we're
married and I wouldn't move in with her
- we're married we agreed on that got
good clarification thank you for that uh
well how old are you sir 29 okay all
right I have a daughter that is 29 and
is married and kids in your age group
some are married some aren't so I'm
going to treat this as if I was
discussing this with one of them because
it's really it's really really important
okay this is a real serious problem that
the two of you have to get some help
solving before you move forward with
your relationship that would be my best
strong old man advice to you okay here's
why there's tons of research that shows
that if you can be an agreement on four
areas prior to being married and have
clarity and agreement on the principles
and how we're going to handle these
areas that your success in your marriage
goes through the roof the chance of
years of your marriage being successful
is very very high if you're in agreement
on these four areas money children
whether to have them how to treat them
in-laws how to deal with them because
it's crazy in every family and religion
if you are not in agreement on any one
of those four or three of those four
then you're going to have statistically
you're going to have major problems in
your marriage that you have to work
through okay and that's advice you know
if I'm looking at getting married I want
to know what the best show it what the
what makes a best kind of a marriage and
one of the things is to be in agreement
on those four things going forward of
those number one cause of divorce number
one cause a conflict
marriage is money it's the number one
and so it is the opportunity to have the
best marriage or the worst marriage
based on how we handle this subject and
you guys have a terrible start you do
you think it's uh do you think it's fair
that she is fast that I so we talked
about that after we get engaged do you
think I I absolutely think that is
ludicrous okay okay and just based on
what I just told you okay
so how do we handle that well if you're
in your shoes because you obviously love
this girl and and so um you know I think
if I were in your shoes I would go back
to her and I would say listen I've been
doing a little bit of research and and
talking to some people in the financial
field because you have just now yeah and
I found that this number one cause of
stress in relationships and in marriages
number one cause of divorce is money and
so we really have got to get this on the
same page and honey if you have got a
huge pile of debt it's not a
disqualifier for me mm-hmm I'm not going
to walk away from you because of that
but I will tell you that if we can't get
on the same page on how we're going to
handle it and can't be open and honest
and authentic with each other over this
area it's a huge warning sign we're
going to have to work through before we
can move forward or if we're going to
move forward okay and in that's a gentle
way I'm not saying throw down and go I'm
gonna break up with you you don't come
clean you know that's not what you're
going to do I'm not asking you to do
that I'm not suggesting you do that
because obviously you guys are in love
and obviously this is moving forward but
just you know I you know if they said
there's one reason that you have a car
wreck and the person driving is
exhibiting that reason then you got to
go dude I ain't riding with you you know
I got to get you know we got to fix that
for me to ride with you whatever it you
follow me this is the number one thing
it's not like number ten it's not like
it might be a problem it's going to be
huge so we've got to have her where
she's not ashamed and hiding things
where she's not obstinate and angry and
has her
instead we're going to work together I
love you I'm gonna whatever it is we're
going to dig out of it together and you
got to have you know we got to talk this
through together and we're not going to
make major decisions like buying a house
you know we're not gonna make those kind
of decisions if we're walking towards an
altar together by ourselves yeah so
honey what that means is after we're
married or while we're engaged I'm not
going to come home and go I just spent
$29,000 on a bass boat I hope you like
it I'm not going to do that because
you're half of my brain once we're
committed to this thing and so we're
going to work together and I don't need
your permission to buy a bass boat but I
but I want to talk it through with you
and we're going to make decisions
together I'm not I'm not saying you have
to submit to me or you have to bow down
to me that's not the point the point is
we've got to learn to work together and
it in this area is such a big indicator
that if we can't then we've got to work
on it until we can before we can move
forward to engagement and I would know
it I would beg you to not get engaged
and certainly to not get married until
you guys get these two issues resolved
and the two of you and you know I'm
telling you I if it was my if it was
Dave Ramsey son I my son is single if
Dave Ramsey son was going to marry a
girl that had two hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt I would not
tell him to walk away from her based on
that I would tell him to walk away from
her based on the fact that she's hiding
it she's obstinate she's scared she
shamed or that she continues to believe
that that's an awesome thing and she
should keep that debt forever because
he's never going to agree with that if
he's my son right yep and so they're
going to be in constant conflict and I
would say the fact that we can't come
together and be an agreement is a deal
breaker not the debt you see the
difference yeah and so it's it's a
that's why I told you going in the break
it's a real serious subject because this
is a deal breaker if you can't solve it
if you're if you're wise and but you but
I think it's solvable because I think
it's prime
based on your conversation I think it's
more base
and the fact that in shame in that she's
just ashamed and she just doesn't want
you to know how big a mess she's got and
she's afraid you're going to be all
judgmental you know even though you're
even though you might not be even though
you might not have been before this
conversation you know but I wouldn't be
judgmental I would just go hey everybody
messes up as long as we're in agreement
we're not borrowing money and is going
forward as long as we're in agreement
we're going to work to take this thing
out then and fix it then we've got an
agreement the debt the size of it
doesn't scare you you know I guess if
she's got 20 million in debt you may
want to rethink it but I mean but that's
probably not it right is this logical to
you completely and you know I honestly
believe that God does speak wisdom into
you because lots of that is what I
believe to be the case as well and you
are confirming a lot of it I really
really appreciate this phone call cool
well I appreciate you calling in I want
you to hear loud and clear I want our
listeners to heal and Claire I'm not
condemning her for this yep
and I answer we're not walking away
because she doesn't you know cuz she
don't agree with a Ramsey that's not got
anything to do with this this has got to
do with you guys got to be on the same
page and crap you don't even know what's
on the page okay yep thanks for the call
brother good luck with that
you might call back let me know what if
it all works out our listeners would
love to hear
you